[Music]
foreign
I didn't do nothing
[Music]
welcome home what happened to your face
this little going away present from the
boys
unless you're out early you ain't on my
reach boy
you're being awful hard on yourself we
can be forgiven
we're on here ain't no point of keeping
it to secret one of our own shot with
his own pistol which we can't seem to
find
[Music]
get in the truck
turn on the car and drive
well I think I'll hold on to that this
ain't too good
to me I will can you tell me a little
belongs to you I shot him until he
wasn't moving no more no place you can
go somewhere safe but I'm gonna trust
you you're gonna have to trust me
what the hell is going on I need that
old place I'll explain everything later
all right I got your back
a woman came into the shelter little
girl that lady working there said she
found a pistol on her before she took
off running
I just need to know if Russell stayed
here with you tonight before last as far
as I know he was here
brother dead
I ain't looking to be another
[Music]
guy together by some sort of invisible
Road
just do the best you can for right now
you don't worry about tomorrow until it
comes
[Music]
lives of Whirlwind
we're all caught up in it
[Music]
thank you